[Música]
aí eu trago com vocês esse tema belo
monte sonhos realizados e sonhos
despedaçados e o próprio tema ele pode
chegar alguma coisa aqui ou aqui eu
estou me referindo um pouco da minha
trajetória de vida é nasci em 1965 em um
bairro de periferia
no momento em que há o regime militar
era uma coisa muito presente na vida das
pessoas
pelo menos na minha era porque eu via no
local em que é não tinha recursos
não nós não tínhamos televisão telefone
e enfim tudo o que se ouvia falar era
dos vizinhos
então olha é um vizinho ele tem ele sabe
fala vários idiomas ele tem uma
biblioteca vastíssima muito rica e em
função disso é invadir a casa dele tirar
os livros arrancaram tudo então era sim
uma situação de muito medo que nós
vivenciávamos naquela época e ocasião eu
comecei a ouvir falar
já na década de 70 das usinas
hidrelétricas como criança não se metia
em conversa de adulto então a gente
ouvia falar de usinas hidrelétricas e é
sempre com aquele temor vai destruir uma
cidade as pessoas vão morrer as pessoas
vão sofrer e vi que várias indagações em
relação a isso
o foco do meu trabalho belo monte aqui
hidrelétrica de tucuruí década de 70 e
74 75 começou
anton itaipu como belo monte e pensava
meu deus quem é que vai poder ajudar
essas pessoas porque os militares mesmo
sendo muito criança na minha solidão eu
questionava não vai lá no salva no não
tira as pessoas porque os mesmos estão
fazendo isso eu não entendi a mais
nada referente à ocupação da amazônia o
que era esse desenvolvimento eu achava
que tinha alguma coisa errada porque se
dizem que desenvolvimento era pra
melhorar
como é que as pessoas estavam sofrendo e
aí eu assistia muitas vezes na janela do
vizinho tirich razão claro que os mais
jovens não sabe o que é isso mas eram
heróis nacionais que sempre se salvavam
as pessoas libertavam as pessoas das
situações difíceis com jerônimo o herói
do sertão
então era uma coisa assim que dizer por
que eles não podem ir lá e fazer alguma
coisa dentro do meu mundo de insumos
foi algo que foi muito marcante muito
pesado que eu percebia
eu sentia uma impotência muito grande e
não tinha ninguém que me esclarecesse ag
não tinha então meses eu sei que marcou
muito a minha vida
o tempo se passou desde de todas as
adversidades conseguiu entrar na
universidade aos 25 anos com o filho de
4 anos e uma que nasceu prematura de
seis meses mas tudo bem eu sabia que eu
queria eu queria realmente poder fazer
alguma coisa em prol das pessoas que
eram carentes ou vulneráveis
entrei no curso de enfermagem quatro
anos de curso 1 para me formar fui pra
biologia
eu queria algo que fosse muito maior
sempre gostei da área de saúde e foi lá
que eu passei a desenvolver e fazer
mestrado trabalhando com doenças
infecciosas e parasitárias mas ainda
faltava alguma coisa e ministrando aula
em escolas particulares
eu levava o tema e hidrelétrica levar o
tema à discussão hidrelétrica
foi quando eu resolvi usar saídas
biológicas e para o ano xii trabalhar o
que na antropologia hidrelétricas e
fabio antropologia me preparei e sobre
mais nove que o inag novos que sobre
outros antropólogos que faziam em
etnografia e chegou o meu grande dia
fazer campo
eu não sou eu senti uma empolgação tão
no direito daquele avião indo para
altamira visitar a região do xingu eu lá
como pesquisadora e não
com uma vaidade pessoal mas sim vou
buscar conhecimentos vão interagir com a
população que está sendo atingida pela
hidrelétrica de belo monte que
realização maior eu queria
o que esperar de mim anotei
imediatamente todas as minhas possíveis
é tudo o que eu estava sentindo as
minhas percepções em relação àquele
momento porque pra mim também é que é
importante
o que eu achava que eu ia encontrar
cheguei em altamira comecei a conviver
com as pessoas e comecei a perceber a
dor primeiro dia de pesquisa
conversando com pescadores conversando é
com pessoas que moravam no centro urbano
um tal se uma desordem total foco da
minha pesquisa mudanças da epidemiologia
das doenças endêmicas
em decorrência da instalação da
hidrelétrica
mas eu vi outra coisa eu comecei a
perceber pessoas que estavam num
processo de tristeza tão grande uma
epidemia de depressão mas eu vi na
televisão o tempo todo manifestações
pessoas gritando
salve o xingu contra belo monte
não que eu tenha ido é com a ideia que
ali passar o formal falar ou incitar
pessoas contra
não é esse o meu papel nesse papel de um
pesquisador e sim houve houve a primeira
vez à segunda e assim foi até o 5º dia
que eu estava lá fazendo as visitas
eu percebi o local em que eles moravam
as promessas
as grandes promessas de mudança de vida
o desenvolvimento de novo
lembrei lembrei quando eu era criança
é isso padrão europeu como tirar essas
pessoas dessas palafitas que elas viviam
um lugar completamente inadequado
a vida e salobre completamente em
palafitas próximo a rios
isso daqui no lugar que freqüentemente
alagava era rotina deles tanto tempo
alagado tanto tempo seco
no entanto aquilo era rotina deles como
vocês podem observar é numa do dos
bairros uma invasão dos padres
essa é a realidade a ausência total de
políticas públicas tanto a ausência do
município como a ausência do estado
neste ambiente
mas peraí belo monte está chegando belo
monte vai lutar realidade dessas pessoas
elas vão sair daí e elas vão para casas
de alvenaria e não apenas a população
urbana mas a ribeirinha também chegando
lá eles vão ter a vida digna digna em
casas de tijolos roupa sem querer o
projeto mudou na martin jol agora é
concreto mas a nossa casa de madeira tem
um puxadinho que a minha filha mora lá
com o esposo mas tem também o meu filho
que mora lá
então são muitas pessoas e essa casa vai
comportar todo mundo e não se preocupem
cada família ganhará uma casa
então isso não é problema puxa que legal
então o meu filho vai ter a casa dele a
minha filha vai ter casa dela
nós vamos ficar juntos não
necessariamente o recentramento urbano
coletivo
o mais próximo fica a dois quilômetros
do centro urbano em transporte ainda não
mas um dia vai ter não se preocupe mas o
custo de vida aumentou a uma taxa de
r$10
a gente entra no táxi pagar 20 como é
que vai ser isso
bem isso daí ninguém pode falar nada por
enquanto a situação é essa
certo e aí segue se com essa realidade
altamira começou a ser modificada é com
todo esse padrão é de saneamento que não
existia antes na cidade e isso é
benefício sem dúvida nenhuma entre idas
e vindas não só da situação política
local estadual e federal
neto veio avassalador como um rolo
compressor
não importa mas e tristeza como é que
fica
e aí todos foram contemplados não
infelizmente acabaram as casas mas as
outras pessoas foram indenizadas pois
sim e outros não onde existam em algum
lugar na casa de outros vivendo de favor
saíram como amigavelmente
eu não posso sair da minha casa eu não
posso comprar pão na esquina porque eu
tenho medo eu sinto medo porque o seu
risota vel' morador de uma ilha com os
60 e poucos anos com filhos que também
não tinham sabiam escrever assim como
ele
um dia saiu quando ele voltou à sua casa
estava no chão todo que restaram panelas
e utensílios
ele teve que sair de lá levando as suas
memórias e alguns objetos pessoais
alguém pode fazer alguma coisa alguém
pode sim os procuradores os defensores
estão lá pra fazer isso foi resolvido
até agora não
o rio é meu eu pesco no rio e que é o
que eu quero do rio
não você não pode entrar o rio não é
mais eu vou fazer o que me vale uma casa
uma casa de alvenaria uma casa de
concreto não sei fazer outra coisa que
só se pescar a quem me dá emprego e nos
filhos vão passar fome
não entro você não pode passar daqui e
se reúne pertence às minhas raízes onde
estão não sei as casas sem permissão
fizeram os puxadinhos para poder
acomodar as pessoas os filhos e ser o
padrão europeu
rachado a casa já com achada cinco anos
apenas de garantia é o saneamento básico
infelizmente ainda não deu pra fazer
esses tonet eles contem fezes
então em determinada época é exala o
cheiro
desculpa aí mas quem sabe no futuro não
vamos ver que a gente faz porque
apareceram muitas situações as
condicionantes como se existem
condicionantes do projeto adiante
a gente não pode parar o projecto força
nacional está lá a força nacional para
indo nis drones você anda e de repente
você o que é isso está sendo observado
a força nacional está garantido que belo
monte não pode parar porque por causa da
demanda energética belo santa estranho
do ouro não pode parar no pote
eu trouxe uma novela de janete clair
fogo sobre terra
essa novela ela também me abalou muito
porque ela a palavra sobre a
hidrelétrica justamente no momento em
que itaipu começou a se falar de itaipu
e dos danos que normalmente a gente
pensa a floresta o maior dano ao ser
humano que sofre é ele e henry que é
tirado do seu local de origem sem que
seja perguntado qual é o seu padrão de
felicidade é um padrão que
necessariamente tem que ter uma casa de
alvenaria para que você seja feliz
porque o nosso modelo é um padrão e que
separa as pessoas ea água uma história
em que nós sabemos que a paisagem é
fundamental no nosso psicológico
a convivência com rio coisas que são
imensuráveis à cena em que a indígena
que foi representada pela nilza amaral
essa indígena chamava assinará ela se
recusa a sair de nova divinéia
apesar de todas as já a as censuras
militar na época na década de 70
janete clair ousou o líder que promover
todas as situações é contrária ao
desenvolvimento da hidrelétrica nesta
cidade que era a situação da novela foi
impedido de liceu líder dele ser morto
porque se ele poderia ter se
transformado em um martini isso não foi
aceito
por que ele fosse preso por desordem mas
ela usou e ela colocou
significativamente a indígena que se
recusou de apagar sua história
dc de ser arrancada de forma abrupta do
local em que ela cresceu e do local que
ela era feliz
hoje nós temos as manifestações ainda
por é pedindo justiça que belo monte não
aconteça que outras mais 20 como a gente
sabe que vem ainda mais 23 elétricas
para a amazônia que elas sejam é mais
bem planejadas no sentido de enxergar e
quem não está sendo é visto que é o ser
humano que hoje padece com grupos de
pessoas que vão até o time mira para
tratar da saúde mental delas porque a
morte ela não é só física ela também é
social e muitas pessoas já morreram em
decorrência dessa hidrelétrica
aqui é o grito que não é ouvido
eles não são e mo de sida porque ninguém
tem direito pode acontecer ninguém mas
nem sempre os gritos são ouvidos
essa é a minha trajetória
são os meus caminhos percorridos eu
continuo a caminhar muito obrigada
[Aplausos]